thank you alejandro yes we are here with
a very happy victor of the round there
is christopher repka he's who is perfect
mr perfect in this tournament right now
three out of three chris first of all
congratulations how do you feel right
now thank you i feel great it's not the
start i expected even though it's the
start i was hoping for
and especially today it was uh from the
opening i didn't feel like i was doing
that great i didn't know what i was
doing actually and i was surprised how
fast i achieved an advantage let's uh
look through the game tell us
which do you think are the critical
moments
well i think the critical moment just
one second i'm pulling it up
here
well the
okay the opening was
something that i was looking at but i
didn't look at it for a long while and i
didn't know the move dc4 so i wasn't
very happy right now but i was like okay
knight c3 like that's probably not a bad
move and now i didn't know what to do at
all so i
put my knight on the e5 but i didn't
like that the d4 square is just
so weak i wasn't sure how to evaluate it
and i saw the position
he played knight d4 i think that was all
good and now the critical moment arose
after he takes d4 h3 because i think
that he has two options here he can
either play bishop c8 or he can play
bishop f3 if he plays bishop f3 i think
the positional the position is
simplified maybe it's a tiny tiny bit
more pleasant for white because i have
more pawns on the with my kings and with
the opposite colored bishops i think
it's important to have
a good defense of your king and
he chose to play bishop takes f3 you
would take with i would assume queen
yeah queen takes uh bishop takes queen
takes knight takes d4 did you take on d5
as black or would you play a c6 right
now i was thought that c6 is not that
good because of knight f6 but maybe i'm
wrong
but that was what i was looking at that
potentially i have rook d1 and i gained
a tempe and i thought maybe it's good
because after queen d6 i have e5 and
queen e5 runs into knight d7 fork oh
okay so put that on the board look to d1
queen to d6 and now e5 crucial move full
of tricks
yeah that was my trick but he didn't go
into this
i think he should have maybe but bishop
c8 at first looked very dangerous
because i was looking at it and i'm like
i cannot take on d4 because c6 97 queen
e7 and despite the fact that i'm upon up
he has just
the b2 is hanging and he is threatening
rook d8 he has two bishops well i think
you're just losing that extra pawn next
move yeah i might even be losing period
because i don't like this position
you have to go knight b3 or knight c2 no
that's just very scary very sad so i was
happy to have but i saw this
a few moves back and i saw the move
rookie one which i was happy with and
now i think it was another crucial
moment he played c6
which i think helped me because
yeah even the computer agrees with me
because knight f4
e5 e6 was my only plan in the position
and i thought that instead of c6 if he
played c5 despite the fact that my
knight is
pretty good on d5 i think he has two
bishops he has a nice pawn on d4 and i
think it's just a position i am not sure
who's better i felt like black could
potentially be slightly better
all right so c6 helped you out a little
bit and i'm sure you were very happy
to see the move c5 played in this
position
i was happy to see the move a5 played
because uh i wasn't sure after e5 how to
even defend against e6
i didn't like his move a5 i think he
underestimated my attack there
so i think after c5 you play this move
e6 breaking through
and i believe f5 was a complete blunder
what the the engine was mentioning here
was g5 g5 i would consider this move i
was looking at it i was thinking that
g5
usually is not good
and i was looking at it it's a bit messy
but i thought that i should find a way
to be
at least slightly better maybe take on
f7 knight yes something simple like that
i just thought his king is so weak that
even though he has some things going for
him it's probably slightly better for me
and in the game uh after move f5 it
seemed like this clamp he just was
unable to get out of it of course upon
e6 and monster the bishop 1g2 a monster
the knight on f4 is great and nothing is
going right for the for the black side
yeah i think what he was afraid of he
played f5 if you go a little bit back
he was worried he thought that he would
play queen d6 probably
but what i was planning after queen d6
was e takes f7 rook takes f7 knight d3
to threaten knight e5 and after knight
c6 i have knight d2
threatening both knight e4 and bishop d5
that was my plan
it feels like black is just down
development 10 piece yeah yeah
which he kind of graciously gave with
the move a5 a5 c6 c5 yeah he lost too
many times g4 bishop c8 yeah this is too
many i think maybe not even that many
like one too many maybe two too many but
that's all the game takes and it felt
that this after this position you're
just cruising towards a victory
well chris a incredible start there
three out of three
as this game is over right now i believe
that one was a draw as well
yep yes
alex managed to survive alex did manage
to survive that slightly unpleasant
position but he is a very resourceful
player
well chris congratulations uh three out
of three what are your ambitions right
now for the tournament i'm just gonna
go get some dinner and play it game game
by game i realized that it's such a long
tournament with very good players and
i'm just grateful for to be in the
position i'm in and yeah we'll see what
i make out of it well congratulations
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next rounds thank you
absolutely so we do have